There are an estimated...
this many individual viruses on Earth.
Luckily, there are only a little over
1,000 virus strains
known to infect humans,
the majority of which
come from other animals.
They're part of a group
called zoonotic diseases,
caused by bacteria, viruses,
parasites, or fungi.
And the one we're all focusing on now
is the virus that causes COVID-19.
And new ones can emerge at any time.
Here's what needs to happen
for a virus to jump
from animals to humans.
As a pathogen, the virus' goal
is to infect its host and replicate,
because it can't do that on its own.
Let's say this pig is the
original host of a virus.
He and his buddies form a reservoir,
a specific population of
animals of the same species
that naturally host a pathogen.
Colin Parrish: So, there are
millions of viruses out there
infecting animals. Literally millions.
I mean, the more we
look, the more we find.
And most of those viruses
don't infect, you know, other animals.
They have a restricted host range.
Narrator: Most of the time, the virus
doesn't affect its original host
or only mildly affects it.
So, what's it doing in there?
Suppose that this pig hosts a virus
that primarily infects the gut.
Viruses tend to attack
different parts of the body,
depending on whether they
can bind to these guys.
Receptors are proteins found
along the outside of a cell,
used to communicate with
the rest of the body.
But viruses can latch on, too.
Cells in a respiratory system
may have different receptors
than cells in a digestive tract.
A virus does its thing by
latching onto a host cell,
entering it or injecting
bits of itself into it,
and then hijacking it.
It forces the cell to
make copies of the virus,
all of which will go on to
hijack other host cells.
This will usually kill the host cell.
And if enough of the
host cells are infected
and make more of the virus,
the host will contract an infection,
which, if the body can't fight
it off or fights too hard,
could lead to severe disease or death.
In reservoirs, however, the
species has likely evolved
a resistance to the virus
over many generations.
This allows a sort of equilibrium;
the immune system controls the infection
without killing the virus off completely.
If the virus jumps, though,
a new host won't have that
same, or any, immunity.
That might sound scary, because truthfully
you are constantly being
exposed to viruses.
But only a very small number
succeed at infecting a new host species.
It's called spillover,
and there are a series of barriers
that a virus must navigate
for that to happen.
If it's held up by even one of these,
it can be stopped in its tracks.
Simplified, they represent two things:
Can the virus get to the new host's cells,
and can it bind and enter them?
The more infected pigs
there are in one space
and the closer they are to people,
generally the more chance of spillover.
But the likelihood also has to do with
how the humans are interacting with them.
Animal viruses are usually
transmitted to people
in a few ways: contact with excretions,
slaughter, bites, contact with tissues,
or through an intermediate species
like mosquitoes or ticks.
So places like farms and slaughterhouses
and even petting zoos,
where people come in close
contact with animals,
have an increased risk of spillover.
Proximity alone isn't enough, though.
Some of it can be genetic for humans.
There's a huge list of genes
that have been associated
with different risks of infections,
some genes offering resistance
to certain infections
and others increasing risk.
Beyond genes, the virus has to get through
the body's innate immune responses.
Parrish: So, there's two
types of immune responses.
One is the simple
adaptive immune responses,
so those are antibodies and T cells,
and they generally get stimulated
after the infection has already occurred.
The innate responses are the
ones that are already present
inside the cell that
make a cell or a host,
you know, resistant to the virus.
Narrator: Unlike an adaptive response,
an innate one can attempt
to fight off any pathogen
rather than a specific one.
Mucus membranes, stomach
acids, skin, sentinel cells,
and even just a lack
of the right receptors
can stop a virus from infecting a person.
So, this is when mutations
are really important.
A successful spillover
usually doesn't happen
with the original virus.
Parrish: They have to gain some mutations
that allow them to
replicate most efficiently,
allow them to overcome
those host barriers.
Narrator: A virus that infects
the digestive system of the pig
might attack respiratory cells in humans.
It depends on what receptor
the virus is suited for
or mutates to be suited for.
Once inside the new host cell,
an infection will only be successful
if the virus can replicate.
Typically, infected cells
will release interferons,
proteins that stop the
virus from replicating
within the cell and in nearby cells,
which contain the infection and stop it
from spreading to new cells.
If that doesn't work,
the adaptive immune system kicks in.
Your T cells suss out and
kill already infected cells
to stop them from making more new virus,
while your white blood
cells pump out antibodies
specifically tailored to
fight this new pathogen.
But because the body has
never seen this virus before,
it can take weeks to
produce the right ones.
And immunodeficiencies in
either type of response
can make it even easier
for a virus to take hold.
So, if a virus gets through all that,
contact, infection, replication,
then it has successfully spilled over.
But...
Parrish: The virus has
to be able to transmit.
It has to be able to be shipped
from that original person,
and it has to be able to infect, you know,
at least one or two more additional people
so that you can start a
chain of transmission.
Narrator: A virus infecting two people
has double the odds of going
on to infect additional people,
compared to a virus infecting just one.
And this can continue until it reaches
epidemic and pandemic proportions.
COVID-19 was certainly not
the first zoonotic disease,
and it won't be the last.
Viruses don't want to kill their hosts;
no host means no virus.
But new diseases are so dangerous
because humans don't
have the same immunity
as the virus' reservoir host.
And because there are so many,
it's currently not possible to predict
when or what specific
viruses will spill over,
but we do know the conditions
in which spillover can occur.
Parrish: You know, how
and where they might occur
and how we can put in place sort of
better monitoring so that
we can catch them early
and, as they say, stamp them out
before they get to the
point where they become
sort of an out-of-control epidemic.